hi I'm Josette Sheeran head of the World
Food Program in Davos many of you may
know that were the world's largest
humanitarian organization and many of
you may know that we feed people all
over the world including 3 million
people in Davao in dark water every day
what you may not know is with the cash
we have which is half our budget we
procure spend eighty percent of them
procuring from farmers in more than 70
developing nations and so today when we
fill this Cup of schoolchildren in
Mozambique eighty percent of that food
comes from local farmers that food would
never be seen on global markets because
they don't have the transportation and
the ability to move it so the world
school program goes to the farms risk
gets the food and fills the cup this is
a win-win solution and we're very proud
of the fact that we spend almost 700
million dollars a year procuring food
from small farmers throughout the
developing world to help these people in
Darfur to help feed school children all
over the world so help give us support
for these local farmers and break the
cycle of hunger right at its root thank
you